joe biden finally breaking his silence
and denying that he ever
sexually assaulted his former senate
aide tara reid
it is not true i'm saying unequivocally
it
never never happened and it didn't it
never happened
i'm not going to question her motive i'm
not going to get into that at all i
don't know
why she's saying this i don't know why
after 27 years all of a sudden this gets
raised i don't understand
it but i'm not going to go in and
question her motive i'm not going to
attack her
she has a right to say whatever she
wants to say but i have a right to say
look at the facts check it out find out
whether any of the what she says
is asserted or true
biden also under pressure to release
senate records his accuser says
could show that she filed a complaint
back in 1993
the former vp says he's confident a
complaint doesn't exist in the national
archives or
at the university of delaware where his
senate records are being held
i am absolutely positive that no one
that i'm aware of
ever has been made aware of any
complaint
a formal complaint made by or a
complaint
by tara reid against me at the time this
allegedly happened 27 years ago
a record like this can only be one place
it would be at the u it would not be at
the university of delaware my archives
do not contain personal files
my archives contained document and i
said when i say personal
personnel files they don't contain any
personnel files
and president trump weighing in on the
biden allegation
i would just say to joe biden just go
out and fight it
it's you know one of those things but
i'd say
he has far or she's far more convincing
than blasey ford
or the other three that i believe have
already recanted
dana i just wanted to start with you uh
and say do you think that joe biden did
a good job
i think he probably did better than his
team was thinking but you know they had
five weeks to prepare
i think waiting for the media frenzy to
get to such a high fever pitch that you
even had you know the new york times
shaming them into not actually taking it
on and doing an interview
i thought mika brzezinski at msnbc had a
tough questions for him i don't think
anybody can say that was a like a super
easy interview for him
he opened himself up for some skepticism
though on this point about the documents
the national archives saying
no actually we don't have those that
would be in your personal papers
at the university of delaware and it is
a little surprising to me again
knowing for five weeks that this was
coming that they haven't
gone to the university asked for the a
full investigation
and been able to either produce or not
produce it so i think that they're
vulnerable on a couple of points
and then on the substance of it of
course vulnerable on
the whole points about the hypocrisy now
i understand that you know politics and
hypocrisy go hand in hand and if you are
accused of hypocrisy of
saying one thing about the candidate you
support and then
something else against an opponent of
that candidate
then you can always rationalize that you
can bring it up but
you know in this case the democrats have
walked themselves into this corner
and tara reed is said to
be she should be allowed to come forward
she's allowed to do interviews she would
do all of these things
i don't know exactly what will happen
next because
they are calling for an investigation of
some sort but i believe that the next
battle is going to be about these
documents
and let me just say one other thing
right now the democrats are all standing
behind joe biden
and you haven't heard much from them in
the last several weeks a few of the
vice presidential shortlist candidates
have been saying that they support him
nancy pelosi said joe biden is joe biden
but if you start to see any high-profile
democrats start to
walk away or to show a little bit of
daylight between joe biden and them i
think that you will see
a whole rash then and at that point we
might be
watching some really interesting history
unfold
as we're 26 weeks away from the
presidential election
well jesse uh when president trump uh
went through this kind of thing he
denied it
uh so now you have joe biden denying one
allegation not a pattern but one
so do you take him at his word the way
that you took president trump at his
word
yeah i mean you have to take the person
at their word but you also
just have to find the facts and they
haven't really investigated this the way
they did investigate
blasi ford i mean to dana's point
if i had five weeks to prepare for one
interview
boom home run i'd give joe maybe a
stand-up double here
i thought his tone was good mika was
strong but i don't know if he convinced
anybody either way voters are just going
to have to
never know the truth and just factor
this into their decision in november
he left himself vulnerable for sure when
mika asked if he remembered reid
he dodged and his obvious kavanaugh
standard about believe
all women has evolved it's now believe
all women at first
and then investigate them now a lot of
people would think
investigate and then believe
i'm not really sure what he believes i
just think he knows
he needs to say what he needs to say to
get out of that question
the records thing really opens up a can
of worms first
if you're gonna say there's senate
records of
sexual harassment complaints that the
public hasn't seen
i mean we already know they've settled
massive amounts of lawsuits
and done tons of payouts yeah like what
makes you think we're just going to look
at joe's records
why not the current senators i mean how
far back can you go
and then the delaware thing we already
know his operatives snuck in there and
we're squirreling away
records they got caught by business
insider it's like remember
sandy berger they called him sandy
burglar was stuffing documents in his
pants after the clintons missed al qaeda
i could see that happening but why did
joe biden
say that in his personal records there
are transcripts of conversations he had
with vladimir putin
why would he say that you don't think
the president's going to turn up the
heat on that and say
joe release the transcript i released my
transcript mine was perfect what about
yours
so this isn't going away anytime soon
all right hey greg take a listen here's
joe biden
talking about justice kavanaugh
if they come forward and say something
that is ex
that they said happened to them they
should start off with the presumption
they're telling the truth
then you have to look at the
circumstances and the facts
and the facts in this case do not exist
they never
happened and there's so many
inconsistencies in what has been said in
this case
what i said during the kavanaugh
hearings was that she had a right to be
heard
and the fact that she came forward the
presumption would be she's telling the
truth
unless it's proved she wasn't telling
the truth
so greg does this give the democrats
cover
holding to that standard that people now
i've heard from tara reid people have
vetted tara reid and now joe biden has
spoken on terrorists
yeah and i'm gonna take biden at his
word i presume that she's telling the
truth
because that's exactly what he said they
haven't disproven it
they haven't disproven it so we have to
presume she's telling the truth
look uh biden was doing great
in that interview until he confessed
you know first he had the total denial i
thought that was pretty good the denial
was pretty strong
and then he says that's a complaint you
know i don't know why all of a sudden
27 years this gets raised
what is this what is this that's
interesting
i would pursue that they also didn't
bring up a lot of the corroborating
very tough word to say corroborating
evidence like what about the phone call
into larry king i thought that was
interested that was interesting that was
around the 90s
i think what's fun is watching the pro
biden response
which is almost word for word what their
their side would have mocked
when presented in defense of kavanaugh
so they're apoplectic
over a single segment interview of their
candidate
the kavanaugh thing why you can't
compare it went for days
he was grilled by teams of salivating
lawyers
and mika ruffles their feathers with one
segment shut up you're a bunch of
hypocrites
um again the argument will always be
about consistency everybody's brought it
up
uh but if you said believe all women
then you got to destroy joe biden
so theoretically joe biden has to take
joe biden out
unless he says hey this whole believe
all woman thing
it only suits us politically so i'm
actually not a sexual harasser
i'm just a shameless hypocrite that will
ruin you politically
given the opportunity lastly i've
noticed an
epidemic of people getting hoisted by
their own pitard
batard's a box that holds a bomb i love
that one number one de blasio gets
busted for violating rules
uh that he enforced and wanted people to
gnark on others
number two uh you saw the dudes that
tried to uh frame uh
michael flynn framing themselves and now
you got a guy
who was right up there me too and
kavanagh getting me to
himself by himself so i find this
epidemic
to be extremely interesting
look spider doing push-ups all right is
that fun
yeah it's friday it's friday katy pepper
everybody
come on katie uh the vice president has
said that
a woman will be his vice presidential
choice he's named the panel this week
so what happened today the denial the
whole episode is that going to
impact who the choice is i think you
know right now you've got
senator harris senator klobuchar senator
warren
and former uh house rep stacy
abrams from georgia
well first i think the news that came
out of this interview today
is not that he denied it because that
was obvious what is he supposed to say
yeah i did it let's move on
of course that he was going to do that
the news is that he was finally asked
about it and the president had been
asked about it
multiple times before joe biden was
asked about it so that's the first thing
and i would hope that the media doesn't
just let it go because there
has been one interview about his
response to it
but to your question about the vice
presidential candidate a lot of these
women who
are on the short list apparently for
this position
were worse than joe biden when it came
to what they said about brett kavanaugh
and due process and i thought that the
trump campaign today what they said
in their statement about the vice
president joe biden's record on this
issue
especially when it comes to college
campuses of young men
all over the country and the standard
that the obama administration applied
to sexual accusations on campus
joe biden would have been excel expelled
and kicked out of campus by now
and so i think that if you take the
statements that his vice presidential
candidates made as women
and apply it to the record of vice
president joe biden
people are going to look at this and say
there's an injustice here on one side
women who have valid claims are usually
dismissed ignored
or men are falsely accused and in the
political
arena both of those things are bad so i
think people just feel
bad about it and they want to move on
you know katie does that mean like you
think this has been a setback for the
hashtag metoo movement
i think completely because it shows the
me too movement which we pointed out
from the beginning
was political it wasn't about all women
it was about promoting democratic women
who were able to get democrats more
power in positions that they found
interesting